[Music]
next question
what is the role of god's people in the
final call made to babylon in revelation
chapter 8. very important question
father in heaven continue to speak
through all of us i pray and if there's
someone listening who's under conviction
move that person to accept the truth in
jesus name i pray amen the role of god's
people has always been the same since
adam's sin when god called abraham in
genesis 12 3 he said
i will bless them that bless thee well
let's read for verse 1. now the lord has
said unto abram get thee out of thy
country and from thy kindred and from
thy father's house unto a lamb that i
will show thee and i will make of thee a
great nation and i will bless you and
make thy name great and thou shalt be a
blessing now what was the specific
blessing abraham was to be first three
gives us a clue and i will bless them
that bless thee and curse him that
cursing thee and in thee shall all
families of the earth be blessed if you
read acts 3 25 26 that blessing was
deliverance from sin and so the blessing
of abraham was the blessing of a messiah
to come to deliver people from sin he
delivered them before he gave he'd live
them after he came he delivers them now
and so the blessing that god's people
are to be to the world the function that
we must carry out is by proclaiming the
truth we call people out of false
systems of worship it is not our voice
that calls them it is the voice of truth
but god uses us like microphones like
megaphones like a loudspeaker so people
can hear the message of truth and truth
alone sanctifies error does not sanctify
so our function our function as god's
people is unashamedly and without
hesitation to issue the loud cry which
is come out of her my people come out of
what come out of a system that
disregards law god by disregarding his
law and you disregard god's law by
simply disregarding one there's no need
to disregard all my you effectively do
so by disregarding one we're calling
people out of systems that may of not
affect the law of god this is the role
of god's people you must make that call
but they must live the call that they
make so that the life they live is the
power
of the call of course that power being
the spirit of god working through them
so yes we must preach the truth but we
must also live the truth so when your
co-workers observe you at the office
your colleagues observing the classroom
or wherever
that is part of issuing the call
and that call must be bold
because there's little time left this
call must be bold
i didn't say harsh i said bold so no one
is confused did he say the seventh day
the sabbath yes that's what i said why
did you say that the bible says
balls straight but with love i love this
bowl
amen amen amen the same way abraham god
called abraham to make him a blessing
you see god did not call abraham for his
own sake god called abraham that god
might use him to bless others no one is
ever called for his oral say we are
called to be a blessing to others we
just can't live our lives ourselves we
are called by god tremendous honor to
proclaim a message by voice on my
lifestyle
because the end is near it really is
so true you know elder skeet sometimes i
think if the president of the united
states wants to say you know i have a
job for you to do denisha come join me
or i have a job for you to do john come
join me we would feel so important oh
yes
of the united states
but the creator of the universe yes
calls us uh
and says come
do my work work with me i have a job for
you to do what my humble and high
privilege yes yes
and we're rejected
have mercy